- THANK YOU.
MIKE.
- BRODY.
- YEAH.
HEY, HOW ARE YOU, MAN?
- WHAT'S UP, MAN?
- GOOD TO SEE YOU.
HEY, I'M GLAD I RAN INTO YOU.
WHAT IS THAT JOKE THAT YOU
TOLD RECENTLY AT THE OFFICE?
EVERYBODY IS JUST, LIKE,
GIGGLING ABOUT IT ALL THE TIME,
AND I HAVEN'T HEARD IT YET.
- OH, GOSH.
OKAY.
UM...
ALL RIGHT, IT GOES LIKE THIS.
- YEAH.
- SO, THERE'S THIS WOMAN, AND--
- [laughs]
- OKAY.
- [chuckles] I'M SORRY!
- GOOD AUDIENCE.
- YEAH, I'M SORRY.
I LOVE IT ALREADY.
[laughing]
- AWESOME.
OKAY.
WELL, THIS SHOULD GO WELL.
UM...
SO THERE'S--THERE'S A WOMAN,
AND SHE GOES TO HER DOCTOR.
- SHE GOES TO HER DOCTOR!
IT'S ALREADY FUNNY.
[laughing]
- NO, I HAVEN'T EVEN GOTTEN
TO THE SETUP YET.
- [laughing]
- SO, SHE GOES TO HER DOCTOR,
AND SHE, UM...
SHE SAYS TO HER DOCTOR,
"KISS ME."
- [laughs hysterically]
- NO, THAT'S NOT IT.
THAT'S NOT IT.
THAT--THAT'S NOT THE PUNCH LINE.
- [laughing]
YOU GOT TO STOP ALREADY.
YOU'RE KILLING ME OVER HERE.
- OH, YOU--
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU THINK
THE JOKE IS OVER, BUT IT'S NOT.
IT'S ACTUALLY JUST STARTING.
- [laughing hysterically]
- OKAY.
SO I'M GONNA--
I'M JUST GONNA SPEED UP.
SO SHE SAYS TO HER DOCTOR,
"KISS ME,"
AND HE SAYS, "I CAN'T.
IT WOULD BE UNPROFESSIONAL."
- [laughing]
- NO. NO, NOT EVEN CLOSE.
SHE SAYS--HE SAYS,
"THAT WOULD BE UNPROFESSIONAL,"
AND THEN SHE SAYS,
SHE KEEPS ASKING HIM,
AND HE SAYS, "NO, NO, NO."
HAPPENS THREE TIMES LIKE THAT.
FINALLY, AT THE END, SHE SAYS,
"KISS ME," AND HE SAYS,
"I SHOULDN'T EVEN BE HAVING SEX
WITH YOU RIGHT NOW."
- THEN WHAT HAPPENS?
- [stammers]
I DON'T--I DON'T KNOW.
THEN, I GUESS SHE--
SHE PROBABLY SUED HIM
FOR MALPRACTICE?
- [laughs]
SUED HIM FOR MALPRACTICE.
[hysterical gibberish]
- SO YOU KNOW THAT WASN'T--
THAT WASN'T THE PUNCH LINE?
- THAT WASN'T THE PUNCH LINE?
- NO. THE PUNCH--
- THERE'S MORE?
[laughing]
- NO, THERE'S NOT.
THERE'S NOT MORE.
- THERE'S MORE TO THE JOKE?
- NO, THERE--
THERE'S ACTUALLY LESS.
- WELL, THAT'S IT!
YOU TURNED IT AROUND!
- NO, THERE'S--
- YOU TURNED IT AROUND!
- THE JOKE--
- HE SAID LESS!
- THE JOKE WAS--
- THERE CAN'T BE LESS.
- THE PUNCH LINE WAS THE ONLY
PART THAT YOU DIDN'T LAUGH AT.
- [laughs]
WHAT THE [bleep]?
YOU GOT ME!
- YOU GOT ME.
YOU WERE DOING A JOKE
THE WHOLE TIME!
YOU WERE DOING A WEIRD CHARACTER
THE WHOLE TIME.
- OH, MY GOD, YES.
YES.
I LOVE THE MALPRACTICE STUFF.
THE MALPRACTICE PUNCH LINE
IS HILARIOUS.
- SO YOU WEREN'T DOING
A CHARACTER?
- WHAT CHARACT--WHAT CHARACTER?
- OKAY.
THIS IS SOME CRAZY [bleep].